kaya gerber is showing love for her
boyfriend jacob elordi
it's undeniable the 19 year old model
celebrated the actor's 24th birthday on
saturday
with a steamy instagram post in his
honor kaia shared a shirtless photo of
her man
while keeping it short and sweet writing
happy birthday my love
i could never have imagined something
better the couple has been dating for
nearly a year
having been spotted together for the
first time in september 2020.
at the time a source told et that things
are really great
between them they've been spending a lot
of time together and seemed super happy
it was a real dream come true later that
month the pair even took a trip to los
cabos mexico with kaia's parents cindy
crawford and randy gerber
in 2017 etie spoke with the model and
her mom before kaya started dating
she hasn't had like the first boyfriend
yet and if randy and presley have
anything
to say about the last one that would
have an issue with it like
they'd first have to get through my
brother and my dad so she wouldn't
yeah if they got through them she'd be
ecstatic but
that'd be easy yeah so dad's the tough
one when it comes i mean my brother is
really the toughest
especially because he's close to my age
so he knows everything yeah he's really
the toughest and he knows some of the
kids too
yeah he hasn't believed he presley has
an opinion about it so he would have to
approve
yeah he would like to approve he would
he thinks he has approval yeah
the two made their relationship
instagram official on halloween
jacob dressed as the king of rock elvis
presley and
kaia channeled his ex-wife priscilla
it's exciting it's really cool
in may kaya opened up about her
relationship with the actor which is
really rare for the model who typically
keeps details about her personal life
pretty private this is insane during an
interview with vogue for the june july
issue
kaya said jacob has helped to realize
the limitless boundaries of love
saying quote being able to be with
someone i trust
where we don't want anything from each
other having a safe steady relationship
like that
has really opened my eyes to the
possibilities of love and what it feels
like to love without conditions
lust is touching other people or wanting
them but love
is really seeing someone jacob has also
been helping his girlfriend with her
acting career
as kaya is set to join season 10 of
american horror story which was
announced in march
kaya who's new to acting said jacob's
been incredibly helpful
because he's gone to drama school and
has years of experience
the brunette beauty was last linked to
pete davidson whom she split with
in january 2020 while jake updated
kissing booth co-star joey king
it's you know it's always been you
the actor was also previously linked to
euphoria co-star zendaya
whom he gushed about working with in
2019.
i'm a massive fan so so when i found out
that she was going to be in the show i
was pretty stoked um
she's a she's she's brilliant you know
she's beautiful and she's a she's a
wonderful performer and she just
captains the ship perfectly fast forward
to july 2020
et spoke with jacob about the pressures
of dating in the public eye
and admitted that it initially bothered
him just even the fact that somebody
would could be
someone that you don't know knows your
name is quite like disembodying
um for me personally i just it's got
nothing to do with me you know it's like
imagine the store around the corner from
where
you are now and whatever people are
talking about it's not your business
it's kind of how it feels it's like
unfortunately just has my name involved
in it but it just it literally has
nothing to do with me it just doesn't
affect the trajectory of
my life